years ago people were talking about how
data scientists were the sexiest job of
the 21st century
but suddenly a new contender has emerged
and that's the machine learning engineer
so what exactly is the difference
between these two and is machine
learning engineer just the new
hyped up thing keep watching and we'll
discuss
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
so a while ago i did a video on the
difference between a data scientist and
a business analyst
because i really do think it's important
for anybody who's working with data in
the year 2020
just to understand all the different
roles that are out there as well as to
be in one that's a good fit for
themselves
and certainly a newer role that requires
at least some examination and
consideration
is the machine learning engineer or as
i'm going to call them for the rest of
this video
ml engineer because i'm just going to
get tired of saying machine
learning over and over again and like
any new role
of course comes all the pieces about how
they're losing their jobs
as well as how they're not going to
exist in 10 years
but the first thing i need to mention of
course is all the hype and pervasiveness
surrounding machine learning
in general there's tons of educational
content out there that puts a huge
amount of emphasis on machine learning
and i really do think that gets a lot of
people into data science
because let's face it machine learning
is really cool stuff
but as i've talked about in a number of
my other videos
i think for a lot of people this causes
a pretty serious mismatch of
expectations
because for the overwhelming majority of
data scientists out there
you are not going to spend all of your
time doing machine learning
it is going to come into play sure but
it's not going to be your entire life
for ml engineers on the other hand that
could be a different story
so if you haven't yet seen my video on
the difference between a business
analyst and a data scientist
i do recommend watching that one first
and i'll have a link to that in the
description as well as a card up above
but in this video we're going to talk
about the exact same kind of things
we're going to look at how do you
actually define a data scientist versus
an ml engineer
what are the educational requirements
for each of them what does the money
look like for these two roles
what does the future have in store for
these two roles
and then exactly how do you decide which
one of these two that you want to get
into
now before we get into all that fun
stuff just a few asks
number one please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already also take
one second and smash the like button
because that really does help my content
get suggested more and reach a larger
audience
also i will have a link to my patreon
account in the description of this video
so if you're willing to support me that
way that would be massively
massively appreciated starting with
definitions
so i've gone through the definition of a
data scientist in my videos
so many times that people who've been
following me for a while probably think
that i sound like a broken record
but here it is again in my view a data
scientist
is a professional who excels at four
different things
and those are statistics programming
domain expertise
and communication and sure everybody out
there is going to have some different
strengths and weaknesses
but those are the four pillars of the
field so it is a super technical
position
but it is one that also involves
storytelling the fundamentals of
business
and an overall very human component
now the description of a data scientist
is going to vary around
pretty substantially depending on who's
creating a job listing
and quite frankly so is an ml engineer
but i think the most thorough definition
of an ml engineer
is one i found from a medium article
written by thomas dudek
who's another ml engineer he described a
person called a machine learning
engineer
as somebody who asserts that all
production tasks are working properly in
terms of
actual execution and scheduling abuses
machine learning libraries to their
extremes
often adding new functionalities ensures
that data science code is maintainable
scalable and debuggable
automates and abstracts away different
repeatable routines that are present in
most machine learning tasks
brings the best software development
practices to the data science team
and helps them speed up their work
chooses best operational architecture
together with the devops team
and looks constantly for performance
improvement and decides which
ml technologies will be used in
production environment
then here's another description which i
think is probably going to be pretty
representative of this role in general
we've got somebody who works with data
scientists and business analysts to
frame problems in a business context
builds data pipelines that pull data
from various sources
builds and maintains learning models and
machine learning infrastructure
selects appropriate data sets and data
representation methods
designs experiments and analysis
methodologies that are statistically
rigorous
runs machine learning tests and
experiments performs statistical
analysis and fine-tuning using test
results
builds a user interface to interact with
ml models through simulations
visualizes model metrics and collects
domain expert feedback
and participates in code reviews to
ensure code quality and share best
practices and experiences with their
team
so typically what you're probably going
to see is a data scientist will help get
the project off the ground
define what the right problem is and
help figure out
what ml model if any is appropriate to
build in the first place
then later the ml engineer will use
their tool of choice
which could be python or it could be
things like c
or c sharp to engineer ml models into
production
in such a way that they're scalable and
stable and then i think it's fair to
think of data scientists as typically
more technical in their roles than
business analysts
but then ml engineers are yet another
step above that
and even more technical than most data
scientists
all right so now that we've gone through
the definitions let's talk about
education
so i do detail the educational
requirements out there for data
scientists in my video on business
analyst versus data scientist
but i'm going to quickly rehash some of
those things here
starting with the fact that data
scientists typically have quite a lot of
education
so in 2019 birch works did a study
and they found that a full 47 of data
scientists that they surveyed
had a master's degree and yet another 47
percent had a phd
now i have seen some other research
suggesting that the percentage of data
scientists that hold advanced degrees
is closer to about 70 percent but
regardless there's no question that data
scientists are an incredibly educated
bunch
and most of their degrees are going to
come in statistics or computer science
but these days more and more
universities are offering programs with
specific data science degrees
so that's pretty cool i couldn't find
any similar surveys breaking this down
for ml engineers
but i think it's pretty fair to assume
that a very similar number of them
are going to need advanced degrees then
their education is going to span
probably across computer science as well
as mathematics
and of course ml engineers are going to
need to know programming languages
so this is from springboard and they
cite a report from ibm
so this basically says that machine
learning engineers should know the
following programming languages
ranked from most important to least
important python
java r c plus plus c
javascript scala then julia
then obviously to be a machine learning
engineer you're going to want to be
acquainted with machine learning
algorithms
so this one is from discover data
science now notably here
i think they're omitting neural networks
and modern deep learning techniques
but for the most part this list looks
pretty decent to me
and covers a lot and certainly if you
know these things you're going to be in
pretty good shape
they've got some of the most widely used
algorithms as decision trees
naive bayes classification ordinary
least squares regression
logistic regression support vector
machines
ensemble methods clustering algorithms
pca singular value decomposition
and independent component analysis next
item to cover here is the reason 80
percent of you probably clicked on this
video
and i'm talking of course about money
now if you ask how much money
each of these two roles make the two
second answer to that is
lots and lots of it and you already know
this if you've seen my business analyst
and data scientist comparison video
but glassdoor lists the average data
scientist salary
at 113 309
at this time the most up-to-date
information i could find from indeed
which is from february 2020 had the
average data scientist salary
at 122 338 dollars
granted this is all just for the united
states
but their report from then was pretty
good and i'll have a link to it in the
description
they also do a pretty nice breakdown by
state too
unsurprising to anybody you're probably
going to make
quite a bit more money working as a data
scientist in california than you are in
arkansas
now as far as the ml engineer job is
concerned and
how much money you're going to make from
that i have good news on that front too
indeed reported in 2019 that the average
base
salary for an ml engineer was
and forty six thousand and eighty five
dollars
not only that but they ranked it as the
number one job
in terms of growth between 2015 and 2018
with a whopping 344 percent growth
in number of job postings over that time
period
glass door currently has this number
quite a bit lower than indeed does
but it's still clocking in at 114
121 dollars per year on average
and my guess is this one is on the lower
side since it's based on only 387
salaries
and it's probably disproportionately
coming from regions with lower average
salaries
either way though i think it's a fair
assumption that ml engineers are
probably making a little bit more than
data scientists do
generally but they're both doing
fantastic
and if you're working in either of these
two roles you really shouldn't be
hurting for an income at all
so now the question is what does the
future hold for these roles
and in my video about whether or not
data science will die in five years
i detail exactly what i think and why
but i'll reiterate the main points here
basically i think
data scientists are going to get a
little bit more clarity around their
roles
and there's going to be some more
industry-wide consensus on what a data
scientist
does and actually is and with that
increased definition
is going to come the realization for
some organizations
they need more machine learning
engineers but then a question a lot of
data scientists will have to ask
themselves
is how technical they want to be several
years down the road
in their career and i think the data
scientists who are the most technically
inclined
will shift over towards becoming ml
engineers
just so they can chase a little bit
extra money and their love of neural
networks but then i think data
scientists who don't necessarily want to
be
super technical their entire life will
gradually transition into becoming
experts in their specific domain now to
be fair
at the beginning of this video i showed
you some medium headlines which were
suggesting that
ml engineers are losing their jobs and
that the job in general is just going to
go away over the next 10 years
those are interesting perspectives that
are worth reading and i'll have a link
to them in the description
but if i were to summarize their points
pretty quickly
we are in an economic slowdown right now
and in a lot of places
ml and research jobs are going to be the
first thing on the chopping block
and there's a theory going around the ml
is going to become just a commonplace
requirement
for software developers in the future
particularly as a little bit more of it
becomes automated and it becomes more
accessible
and i really do disagree with this
sentiment because
as ml and ai become more accessible
it opens up more of people's time which
means the problems we all work on
are probably going to get more complex
and challenging
and most of the software developers i
know are wonderfully smart people
but they have to do so much and know so
much without worrying about
learning convolutional neural networks
on top of all of that
and that brings us to the final question
about which one is right for you
and the only correct answer is the
classic lawyer's answer
that is it depends for this one i'm
going to offer a personal perspective
that i hope is resourceful for others
so i personally love the human side of
data science
i love storytelling with visualizations
and i love using data to help drive
strategy and decision making
all that stuff i also really love the
technical stuff
but in about six years that i have of
being in data science
it's happened on a few occasions that
i've gone super deep into machine
learning and building cool models
sometimes even working on the exact same
problem for several months
and it's happened every single time that
after the initial
fun and joy wore off it did get really
old after a while
and eventually i just couldn't wait to
be working on something else
but that's me some people really do just
want to have more of a code monkey type
position
or they just love computer science and
machine learning so much
that deep diving into that type of stuff
for years at a time
really doesn't bother them but for me
also as a person who comes from a
statistics background
rather than as a computer science
background i'll take work that i enjoy
more and that i find fulfilling
any day over the extra ten to twenty
thousand dollars a year
that an ml engineer might offer having
said all of that i have met tons of
people with some
truly genuine love for machine learning
and for algorithms in general
and if that's you you probably are going
to be more in your element as an ml
engineer
than you would be as a data scientist
overall though
this decade is already shaping up to be
pretty crazy
so who knows what the future holds for
these two roles
and you have to decide based on your own
individual interests and skills
whether a data scientist or ml engineer
role
is better for you but my best guess is
regardless of whichever one that you
pick you're going to be in heavy demand
in the future and you're going to be
loading your wallet up with a lot of
pieces of paper that are green
and have benjamin franklin's face on
them so thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it and you'd like to
support my work do please consider
sharing this video and again please hit
the like button
and then also leave me a comment down
below and let me know which one of these
two you prefer
and why then i'll see you all in the not
so distant future
until then richard on data